ça
[Musique]
c'est une image incroyable un acte
héroïque qui fait beaucoup de bien
dimanche en début d'après midi un
incendie s'est déclaré dans un
appartement à nantes à l'intérieur de
cet appartement un coupé un bébé de six
mois pris au piège alors qu'un terrible
drame semblait se dérouler sous les yeux
des voisins paniquaient plusieurs jeunes
du quartier ont eu un comportement
héroïque et ont escaladé trois étages
pour sauver la famille en détresse
ça fait tellement plaisir de voir ça
vraiment merci
alors ça combat merci d'être là vous
avez porté des matelas pour sauver le
bébé c'est ça aussi il faut le dire
c'est ça ccg elle a participé à la
chaîne humaine pour monté au troisième
étage et vous kenza vous êtes le premier
témoin du drame
vous allez mobiliser les jeunes alors
kenza comment vous avez remarqué
lincendie qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait mon mari était en bas en train de
bricoler sa voiture et on a entendu des
cris des cris est en cours et il croyait
que c'était une femme qui s'était en
train de se faire battre et donc
finalement c'était vraiment la salle j à
commencer donc
et là on a commencé à arriver sur les
lieux mon mari a demandé à une dame qui
criaient en eau de couper son compteur
et de fermer le gaz et alavés peur et
elle pouvait pas descendre parce que
dans l'escalier il y avait trop de fumée
donc on a contacté les services
justement les pompiers ils ont mis du
temps à peut arriver il ya des habitants
qui ont essayé d'appeler on a mobilisé
les jeunes et bravo pour cet acte
d'humanisme ils sont arrivés à faire une
chaîne humaine a noirci chercher aussi
un mâle plat et du coup on en arriver à
avoir des jeunes devant et derrière
nous avons fait vous vous ai compris qu
un couple et son bébé était pris au
piège bas au moment justement quand la
dame en eaux commencent à crier alerté
justement que nous avons été devant la
fenêtre et le papa qui avait le bébé
carrément dans les mains alors comment
vous avez pris la décision d'intervenir
comment parce que la série qui est une
chaîne humaine incroyable reste un
combat comme vous avez pris la décision
d'intervenir
on n'a pas réfléchi en 505 mouvement ça
c'est fait directement on n'a pas
réfléchi
chacun
à contribuer de la manière qu'ils
pourraient donc dont ils pouvaient ils
avaient paniqué ou pas avait paniqué
vous êtes il faut qu'on laisse aux
branchements on réfléchissait pas on a
foncé
ismaël vous dites que vous avez panique
et forcément vous est difficile avec
panique surtout après quand tu vois un
bébé elle est en train de souffrir elle
arrive ma part espéré en plus avec m'en
parle sur v parce que on n'avait pas
beaucoup de choix à part par la fenêtre
alors vous avez participé à la chaîne
humaine bah oui c'est ben c'était
impressionnant puisque city c'est ça
devait être la panique ont forcément ou
inquiètes sur façon quoi qu'il en soit
on a mobilisé les jeunes on s'est
entraidés et dans un quartier politique
comme ça je sais moi mais c'est le très
beau vraiment je peux je suis vraiment
fier de ce que vous avez fait ton dès
fier dont je m'appuie participé à
l'échelle humaine j'ai un peu trop de
poids